One of the more solid findings of cognitive change in late adulthood is between
two kinds of intelligence: crystallized intelligence and fluid intelligence.
Crystallized intelligence is what we know from experience, culture, learning
and education. Crystallized intelligence is used when we try to solve problems
that we've seen before. Fluid intelligence is a more pure intelligence. It's
raw processing speed, your mental quickness and abstract reasoning. This is
used when we attempt to solve problems that we've never seen before. It might
help to look at these on the graph. Here, we see crystallized intelligence, in
this area. What's clear with aging is that crystallized intelligence doesn't
decline. However, as we see here with fluid intelligence, it does begin to
decline at about middle adulthood.